le sujet très important du moment au
niveau social c'est un cadre européen
pour le salaire minimum l'idée c'est de
dire dans tous les états membres
il doit y avoir une référence de type
salaire minimum qui peut être soit
conventionnel par voie d'accord
collectif c'est le cas dans certains
pays du nord notamment soit par la loi
mais l'idée c'est de dire aucun état
membre ne doit dispenser une notion de
salaire minimum il ya encore un certain
nombre d'états membres en europe qui
n'ont pas de référentiel du tout bon et
le deuxième problème c'est que certains
sont à des niveaux tellement bas que ce
sont des véhicules est en fait l'idée
générale de tout ça c'est de des
contrôles d'un pin sociale et pas se
retrouver avec des états complètement à
la traîne ce qui fait que on n'a pas une
mobilité équitable donc certains m'ont
venir systématiquement travailler dans
des états où ils sont beaucoup mieux
payés pour les mêmes jobs
merce évidemment ils perdent leurs
compétences l'idée c'est vraiment
d'aller vers une convergence vers le
haut on dit en termes de normes sociales
on va pas forcer tous les pays à avoir
60 % du salaire médian en terme de
salaire minimum mais on va quand même
donné des valeurs indicatives qui nous
semblait bonne et deuxième point majeur
surtout inciter à négocier
collectivement
avec un bon taux de couverture sur les
salaires il faut savoir qu elle quand
même des états membres de ce niveau là
est très faible je prends l'exemple la
la roumanie où il n'y a que 20 %
d'accord collective donc les cette
amende
à l'issue de ces textes devront fournir
des éléments de transparence sur le
nombre d'accords progresser des
indicateurs de progrès sur ce nom
d'accord et aussi sur la fixation de ce
cas pour un salaire minimum l'idée c'est
vraiment d'augmenter les référentiels en
europe qui a un salaire décent partout